waiting for Isis to come popping out of
the threshold I leveled my rifle and
watched the doorway as David prepared a
grenade from across the courtyard he
waved it to signify he was ready and I
nodded he crept around the corner of the
Hut toward the door my finger on the
trigger I aimed no more than a foot away
from David as he tossed a grenade into
the room and darted back around the
corner I duck behind cover and counted
out loud 1,000 2,000 3,000 4,000 5,000
boom David was already rushing toward
the smoking doorway as I turned the
corner and hurried to get behind him he
put his rifle on automatic and sprayed
the room with lead Jam he yelled with
his rifle momentarily disabled he ducked
out of the way batter up as soon as
David was clear of the doorway I was
already shooting my own rifle
in I walked in an arc directly in front
of the doorway being sure to shoot into
the room at every possible angle
reloading I stepped back and slammed the
Fresh Magazine into my rifle David
rushed into the room and I followed in
and went right entering the House's tiny
kitchen I quickly scanned for threats
kill count clear there were no no shoot
targets open door I moved to the doorway
toward the dirt floor that lay Across
the
Threshold tunnel I cleared the room and
fired into the tunnel now at my feet
then took further stock of the room
around me Isis sleeping pads and gear
IEDs homemade grenades and other
explosive components littered the floor
screw this it seemed like everything in
the room was designed to kill me they're
all in that tunnel and there's no way
I'm going down there David of course
thought otherwise I had read about the
guys in Vietnam called tunnel rats who
would go into Viet Kong and NVA tunnels
I explicitly remember thinking those
guys were the ballsiest guys on the
planet and that I wanted nothing to do
with it but I took my medical bag off
left it with Shaheen and followed David
into the
blackness